so now the hits meanwhile keep on coming
for the white house after the chaos
we've watched on the southern border an
ice agent telling fox that
illegal migrants with criminal records
are being released into the u.s in
multiple cities
their travel expenses are being paid
with your tax dollars
and the buy administration's tried to
pretty much cover it all up the new york
post front page today calling it border
cover-up and the pictures don't lie we
showed them to you yesterday more today
griff jenkins from the white house with
reaction if there is any griff good
morning there is indeed bill good
morning border patrol officials tell me
they've reached a breaking point this
week now on tuesday our own peter ducey
pressed press secretary jinsaki over the
videos of those single adult mails being
released in multiple communities in
brownsville in san antonio some as you
mentioned reportedly with criminal
records here is what jinsaki had to say
about that
we continue to be under title 42
migrants who cannot be expelled under
title 42 are placed into immigration
proceedings and one of those avenues
could be placement in an alternative to
detention program in the interior of the
united states sometimes that means
moving migrants to other parts of the
united states to move to different
detention facilities
since then that leaked body cam video
showing migrants being flown into a new
york airport under the cover of darkness
one source bill telling fox news ice has
become a quote unofficial coordination
travel agency meanwhile texas governor
greg abbott convened a border meeting
with a dozen state attorneys general
here's some of what he had to say
joe biden does not care that people are
dying today
because of the open border policies
that is allowing fentanyl to come into
our country
on that abbott says texas dps alone has
seized more than 1100 pounds of the
deadly drug fentanyl equivalent to more
than 258 million lethal doses and it's
not just the border governors who've had
enough
gop congressman jim comer says if
republicans take back the house in
november they may push for impeachment
the american people do not want these
people
in their neighborhoods and this is
something that joe biden has snuck
around
it's illegal and i do expect congress to
hold him accountable
now the white house has not commented on
that leaked new york tarmac video the
president heads to pittsburgh today
maybe we'll learn more meanwhile the
news here this morning at the white
house is the president got a cat his
name is willow bill
thank you griff griff jenkins north lawn
dana fox news alert there's a cat all
right let's bring in former director of
new york ice removal former new york ice
removals director tom feely tom i just
want to play a little bit this call for
one everyone to see like just set the
scene for us back in westchester county
in august
you don't want to be somewhere where
the spotlight is yeah
down low as possible a lot of this is
just
no i get
we it tell people because what we don't
want to do is attract attention we don't
want the media yeah like we don't even
know where we're going when they tell us
tom i'm interested in your perspective
on this as somebody who used to do ice
removals
yeah so you know me and my good friend
tom holman have pretty much been saying
this since uh this past august you know
whenever your country is doing something
in the middle of the night it's never a
good thing they've been doing this for
quite a while they take illegal aliens
from the border we really don't know who
they are we don't know if they're cobit
positive we fly them all over the
country and i'm not sure what jen's
talking about but you're definitely not
flying them to detention centers you're
cutting them loose on the street and
then we're never seeing them again so
the reality between what's really
happening and what the white house
thinks is happening couldn't be more
farther apart we had rob astorino on
with us yesterday former westchester
county executive who wants to be
governor of new york he's a republican
just listen to what he told dana and me
and listen to the last line call for
number three guys what he said in our
interview
these people are being relocated to
places like westchester long island the
suburbs and other states and nobody is
informed the communities that are
affected
and we're paying the bill on this the
taxpayers nobody is informed but the
federal government literally is breaking
the law and that's the point the federal
government is literally breaking the law
right you know it
it's not a mystery how our country works
right congress passes laws the president
signs them if you don't like the law
congress should change them if congress
can't change the law because that's not
what the american people want that
should be the end of the story but
that's not what is occurring we're
ignoring the law we're letting illegal
aliens go that have criminal records for
no i mean for what reason to what end is
this administration doing this uh you
you'd have to be if you can't make the
connection to like new york city uh
wanting to give illegal aliens the right
to vote and them just continue to run
over the border and be shipped all
around the country i i don't know what
we can do to help people anymore let me
ask you about the secrecy of it though
because one of the things we heard was
that there was a driver saying i've
picked up basketball teams who had more
security than this
the pilots sometimes didn't even know
where they were going to be flying to
the drivers as i said they don't know
once they get them where they're going
and i agree with you it seemed a little
strange to suggest that they were going
to detention centers that certainly
didn't seem to be the case that perhaps
then they meet up with family members if
they have them here is that the
idea
uh no not from my understanding like the
video shows you're looking at mostly
males between the ages of 18 and 21
but you're always led to believe these
are poor families that are coming across
the border looking for a better life
which isn't the case right now
and
you know the more secretive you try to
get the more
the less people you try to get involved
in something right so when you try to do
these flights at night you try to do it
on minimal staff minimal security you're
trying to leave the smallest footprint
you can
to keep it as secretive as you can and
in you know the administration i know
has been doing this since august and um
i don't see them stopping anytime in
your future it took us so long to get
the video but once you got the video you
can prove it because it's on camera uh
sir thank you for your time
um he's very right about what's
happening in new york think about 800
non-citizens we'll be able to vote in
city elections here very soon in new
york unless they reverse the law go
ahead you're going to make a point
i don't know i have a lot of points a
lot of things going through my head i'll
tell you one okay if i crossed the
border into belgium this afternoon and
didn't have a passport or a visa or
papers the belgian government would not
allow me to continue going into their
country and then let me get on a bus and
travel to another city and just be
a-okay you know what else in belgium you
could not do that what else you do do it
here go negative covet test